yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing meow hmm mere honesty yeah he
don't quite know how this is to be
pronounced okay I play the French
defense for for change and maybe I get
this Queen d5 line I recently looked at
some games with this line more
coincidentally than anything else but
let's play it I it seems to me like you
should be able to get a decent enough
position even with limited knowledge
let's hope this assumption is somewhat
true yeah this is actually one of the
lines that and look and some games I
mean but I honestly can't remember how
it how it goes I think this first round
I think this makes a lot of sense
the bishop coming to c6 and then
eventually maybe to d5 okay so now yeah
I think I'm taking
we go here and the night b5 is probably
not very a thought traveled some because
of oopsie aid and then a6 next yeah
c4 was a little bit weaker and weaker it
was unprotected as what I'm trying to
say unsuccessfully what else to have a
success the the most obvious move here
but I wonder if that is really yeah I
wonder if it's best but if I wonder very
long
the the time situation will get to me at
the end
okay so Bishop to c6 maybe but on the
other hand am I mean I could try to play
on the C file with with the Walker okay
he's trading her a bunch training a
bunch of pieces
yeah isn't isn't this an idea again
playing on the sea farm it's a bit
annoying him yeah I can take let's see
two Falls and they're like rupee one is
up getting b7 back at all I just take
this pawn okay so 93 probably so
let's see if the b-pawn okay well well
if I take it
isn't that an extremely fast pawn 93 a3
now that looks very convincing for black
gay porn basically will promote on its
own and now the night has no squares I
can just play Luke a age next move and
pick up the the piece
sometimes they have problems to
understand in those names what is
actually has often a combination of
words and then I don't quite see what
the combination is but not sure if this
makes any sense if you can decode that
let me know yeah okay it next India bond
in general I think the the Queen's red
line here with Queen t4 it's not
particularly threatening and the whole
line in general with Queen d5 is
probably quite okay I think this is the
main reason why the tower lightly - is
not more popular basically all of the
top players they play Knight c3 when
facing the French on move three the
tirage is less popular but I think the
main reason is this line here with Queen
d5 as the the isolated pawn lines are
always going to be is very slightly
better for white that's no no much
debate there and ninety to ninety six is
better for white anyway I mean must be
due to the space it's not huge but this
is not something that white players I
think would be concerned about
I think Bishop d7 is normal here but I'm
only I'm only trying this out and I'm
not an expert at all
so Bishop d7 the engine is not liking it
that much really like here with a very
shallow depth okay Bishop g5 and taking
and what is the engine giving though
even depth 20 Queen to b3
possibly 95 they never came
yeah again I know I don't quite know
what Bishop d7 I thought this this looks
very logical might be five yeah this is
actually maybe you can question that
because the night is not really at the
end I'm getting to to a useful square
Luke see aid is helpful anyway and yeah
Bishop d3 I'm not sure that I was almost
not yet
threatening to win that pawn on on this
on the bishop let's say he would go rook
to you one yeah this is not an issue as
at the end there is this big fork or I
can just put it on the board
this is fork but as the engine
rightfully put points out that this is
an issue attacking this covering this in
the process and now I actually threaten
Bishop f2 and who takes you form like if
this continue if this goes back I should
be able to win the pawn this is covered
now and the knight is immediately
hanging plus the hook is saying so that
would win so Bishop d3 is fine and then
yet the engine just briefly gave 95 this
is a move that I was actually also
thinking about because this is an
interesting idea trying to play on the
situation that the bishop always covers
so he has to cover the night but I was
thinking exactly c4 and I wasn't quite
sure if this is really helping me you
know where where do I go now probably to
be four to connect somehow to the play
before then I really couldn't figure out
if this is helping me
Queen a6 is normal the knight is not
really great on c3 anyway and that is
the square that seems most likely now
Knight e3 looks looks weird so went back
bishops
six gets very normal and now I decided
to capture on f6 which I think it's
quite accommodating it if you take them
it only makes sense in connection with
we should be fried or otherwise I will
get the bishop pair on top and play
stuff like f5 in particular f5
controlling efore and then Luke g8 where
you get enormous player and potentially
at least on them on the G file yeah if
it or Bishop before has to be the point
but then there is Bishop d4 as I played
and this is just good for black you know
you only have yeah you have the real
solution anymore to this problem the
engine wants to take and play route a b1
nether is stronger and then what my
opponent played but obviously it's quite
comfortable for me the question here is
what the most precise way of playing is
taking on c3 I probably wouldn't have
done it is comfortable I can take and
play b6 I guess yeah that's what the
engine gives B 6 and then King e7 rook
c8 trying to slowly get down and get at
the pawns there is however a likelihood
that I will win the three pawns here
against two and then we are stuck well
I'm stuck with four against three on one
on one part of the board under the king
side this is obviously better for black
but it's not clear if you can win I
would probably think about moving the
King here just King to his seven and
trying to try to increase the pressure a
little bit my King e7 you have to look
at 92 yeah in fact 92 bishop back and c3
it's a slight improvement for what I
mean I'm on the D file
and then the engine gives this this line
and yeah this is a situation where route
d2 is just just doesn't do anything you
have to go back now because this is a
funny way of trapping in some water yeah
okay probably probably have to yes it's
a strong engine move here Bishop to e5
prophylactically moving it away
so that night II - now can be answered
by taking on C - that's a good move and
f1 to get to check on the form
and that weakens the whole position him
like if you do this and now King is 7
after 92 but should be six we do exactly
the same thing as before this is
extremely helpful now because you know
the King is stuck and I get to invade on
the two on the attitude not on the two
will be the square the engine also gives
ideas like this where the rook is coming
this way or this way yeah that's better
better defense for white so very very
nice for black but it's a better defense
and the game
yeah I'm just winning the two pawns and
for absolutely nothing okay guys thanks
for watching